hello internet welcome to glory so the
glory so that overthinks the glory out
of all your favorite glories alors Oh
we're back on the Rick and Morty quick
Theory bandwagon this week to talk about
an episode that I initially dismissed as
just a wacky space adventure during my
first watch season 4 episode 7 s
primordius I mean can you really blame
me it ends with Rick and Morty pooping
their pants in the living room for a
show that requires a very high IQ to
understand this one seemed like a pretty
straightforward sci-fi riff on alien
with a little bit of Star Wars thrown in
for good measure the truth though is
that this is an episode all about
philosophy now I keep your glory so on I
promise this episode will be better than
your college philosophy class and won't
have a guy who sits in the corner with
dreadlocks and brings his acoustic
guitar to class he'll just be you know
down in the comments with his acoustic
guitar to quickly recap the episode
opens on Rick and Morty controlled by
parasites they escaped the facehuggers
and kill them as they explore this alien
parasite society on their way to escape
they discover that it seems to be
worshipful of something called Glory's
aliens plan to glory so earth meaning
take over all its inhabitants
Rick and Morty make a daring escape and
decimate the alien society on their way
out of town feels kind of good later
they realized they left summer behind
how summer did she have fun too after
returning to the planet and finding
summer Rick Morty and us as the viewer
learned that the pace huggers have a
30-minute life cycle of attaching
themselves to the faces of host bodies
pooping out an egg and then promptly
dying wait so all you do is live half an
hour eggs and die yes we love it right
now summer
introduces the revolutionary idea of you
know not doing that okay you guys don't
have to listen to me but I vote you
don't do that and thus a new glory so
society is born we find out that in this
new society Steve the parasite that had
latched on Morty and Bruce the parasite
that had latched on to Rick each had two
different philosophical points of view
and just like that the philosophy is
back in my sci-fi animated series about
farts and poop jokes Steve loves the
plan of this new glory so society where
the lifespan is longer than 30 minutes a
sort of self-chosen evolution Bruce the
parasite controlling reg thinks that the
old ways of living for 30 minutes and
pooping out an egg were better and takes
to glory
to spread his message to the masses the
two of them fight about it oh you care
about his progress in society and
skyscrapers you don't care about biology
how come you haven't laid an egg inside
this old man yeah cuz I do what I want
and then they have themselves the
world's most Awkward makeout session in
a show that I thought had capped itself
out at awkwardness with the dragon
episode the season has just been very
uncomfortable with Rick and Morty's
relationship I'm just saying these two
not only give us one of the most
uncomfortable 15 seconds of TV kissing
that I've ever seen but they also give
us two opposing philosophical arguments
that appeal to nature versus
evolutionary ethics the appeal to nature
is embodied by Bruce this is the idea
that whatever is natural is always gonna
be for the best we were born to plant
eggs and a host and died 30 minutes
later if this is what nature gave us
then it's what we should stick to if
it's not natural and it didn't come from
nature then it's inherently bad so
choosing to not die 30 minutes after
you're born is gonna be a big no-no
Bruce's natural is best mentality seems
a little fatalistic coming from the
perspective of us humans that live 90
plus years but this is far from an out
of the ballpark philosophy and you may
even be living at yourself ever choose
between two things at the grocery store
and pick up the one that says natural or
organic on the label because it must be
the better one this is the appeal to
nature unfortunately the appeal to
nature is largely deemed a fallacy
research in the real world doesn't
support the idea that just because
something is natural it's better and
when you play out an appeal to argument
nature a lot of times you can't even
define whether or not something is
natural in the first place for instance
you might buy a nice organic banana from
the grocery store thinking that it's
natural but it turns out the bananas we
now look nothing like their ancestor
natural bananas
humans have cultivated bananas to look
the way that they do over thousands of
years still natural to eat a banana
after all that human tampering it's
unclear is farming food even natural or
should we be only eating things that we
forage from nature even in the show
Bruce himself preaches a natural life if
he refuses to poop his egg and die he's
sitting around making videos for glory
so tubes shilling for the likes like an
intergalactic Wolfie raps even halfway
across the universe it still feels
really awkward so Bruce is clearly wrong
here writes an appeal to nature is a
fallacy it's been proven many times in
every area to be a fallacy Steve is the
one who's right then onward and upward
through progress he's right right right
well it's certainly tempting to agree
with him after all the movement that
summer starts seems to be moving in the
direction of less death and more
flourishing it's an opportunity for the
people of glory so to live out their
lives they can go to school they can
invent things they create a thriving
metropolis everything seems cool up
until summer decides that she wants to
leave the planet and suddenly they go
from worshipping her as Empress to
executing her she's trying to escape
with her family my time to shine execute
Wow just like that guys no trial no
starting with a simple downgrade of you
know what you don't get to be Empress
anymore but maybe we don't go to
immediately killing you know it's played
for the laughs it illustrates the harsh
truth progress always comes with a cost
and the cost is paid by pretty much
anyone who isn't glory so this is an
example of evolutionary ethics humans
being in the bizarre position that we're
in of not only being able to affect our
own evolution but being aware that we're
doing it are faced with moral decisions
about whether the good of us Trump's the
good of everything else and whether
progress makes it ok to change or
destroy everything around us through
science and technology humans have
drastically altered our own lifespans
fewer early deaths less disease less
threat of starvation all of these are
great things that the cost is that we
modify every habitat that we touch we
take resources away from everything else
in the world we can literally bring
water to a desert but in the process we
disrupt all the places that the water
used to be rigorous testing means that
our pharmaceutical products are safer to
use but this testing process often
involves using animals as our test sub
to the glory so is taking over a new
planet and glorifying them is a great
thing to the humans that are about to be
gloried maybe they beg to differ and so
again we arrive at another Rick and
Morty episode where both sides of the
philosophical argument seem to be wrong
appealed nature sucks but glorious tile
progress at all costs sucks - am I
personally happy about progress you
betcha 150 years ago over 40% of people
born didn't survive until adulthood but
do I always want to live with the guilt
of well living well it turns out the
argument doesn't end here listen to
Bruce's argument again the biological
institutions now all you care about is
progress in society and skyscrapers
there's something more subtle than
progress versus nature implied here
Bruce always talking about wanting to go
back to the old days implies that
Steve's way of life is just progress for
progress as sake if all Steve cares
about is skyscrapers then yeah that is
kind of lame he's saying that there's no
greater purpose to what Steve is
building versus at least if you're
living thirty minutes and pooping out an
egg you know what your purpose in life
is in the end it may well be that Bruce
isn't opposed to progress in and of
itself so much as he's opposed to living
in a society that only cares about the
totems of progress only cares about the
externalities after all the glorious
peace movement hasn't made life better
for Bruce in fact the reason he resents
it is because it separated him from the
one person that he loved a life even a
life that is long and full of flashy
technology and infinite infrastructure
isn't necessarily a life that's
worthwhile if it doesn't have meaning
and that is something that might
resonate with a lot of people especially
those living in first world countries
that are on the cutting edge of what
might be called human progress
paradoxically rates of depression are
higher in wealthier countries than they
are in poorer countries and within those
countries richer neighbourhoods actually
have higher suicide rates than
lower-income neighborhoods there are a
lot of people who may be like Bruce feel
that even if society has improved
they've been left behind or has more tea
points out being stuck in a society
that's obsessed with advancing itself
and squeezing every last bit of
productivity out of every single one of
its working citizens can leave people
feeling like they're just cogs in the
Wow just cogs in the machine I'm sure
you'll make this into a beautiful short
film that your parents will pay for
Morty even Bruce's admission that all he
wants to do is have a family with Steve
is a hallmark of the meaningless
progress machine that plays out here in
the real world I want a family we have a
family today countries that have
modernized have fewer families and
smaller family sizes in 2017 the US
Census reported that only about 55
percent of adults were married which is
a huge huge drop compared to 1960 when
70% of adults were married part of this
might be changing lifestyles but birth
rates have gone down too the birth rate
is now less than half of what it was in
1957 not even all the inevitable kovat
babies are gonna make up for that one
dowel Myers a demographer at the
University of Southern California has a
fascinating if controversial explanation
for this saying quote the birth rate is
a barometer of despair according to
Myers young people won't make plans to
have babies unless they're optimistic
about the future the world and their own
and today's young adults aren't
optimistic about either of those we can
point to quote-unquote objective signs
that society is advancing like the
growth in GDP but in the mind of someone
like Bruce just someone living in the
society progress isn't something that
can be measured in the number of
skyscrapers being built at the start of
the episode we mentioned that Bruce's
guilting of making a logical fallacy
with his appeal to nature not everything
that's natural is naturally good however
Steve himself might be guilty of making
a logical fallacy in the opposite
direction argumentum ad novita Tom for
all of you who don't speak Latin out
there that's appeal to novelty which
claims that something is better just
because it's newer or more modern but
that's false not all change is
necessarily progress in the right
direction in the end the two characters
set aside their differences and settle
on a different path forward let's just
get out of here and be whatever we want
that's evolution that's progress much
like Steven Bruce we also need to find
the middle path as we figure out what
our personal definition of progress is
it's not good to cling to the old ways
just because they're more natural but we
also don't want to fetishize some
abstract idea of modernity and become
obsessed with building society in a way
that actually
leaves people worse off much like lures
Oh human society has advanced in a way
that's allowing us to live a longer
lifespan rather than dying prematurely
at a young age but if we achieve all of
that progress and failed to take the
opportunity to actually live that life
in a fulfilling way then what was it all
for that seems to be the real story and
then they poop their pants on the living
room floor what hey that's just a theory
film theory and make sure you subscribe
because the season of Rick and Morty is
coming to a close and you can bet that
we're gonna have at least one if not two
more Rick and Morty analysis videos
coming your way